-We were talking backstage.
You did a great job
delivering
the Democratic response
to the State of the Union.
-Thank you.
-That has often been fraught,
whether it's a Republican
delivering it
or a Democrat
delivering a response.
Like, Marco Rubio, for example,
had to keep drinking water.
How did you prepare
for this moment?
-I hydrated well and early.
-Okay.
-I used a moisturizing
but not glistening lipstick.
-Okay.
-I practiced wandering in
like I knew where I was
and not like I was just
walking off the stage.
And I prayed really hard.
-And in that moment --
Because I imagine that is --
When it starts is
when you realize
exactly how well-prepared
you are for it.
Did you feel as though --
good about the moment?
-So, we decided to make certain
I said "happy Lunar New Year"
because it was
the Lunar New Year.
That's a hard word to say if
you haven't practiced it before.
-Yeah -- Lunar New Year.
-Yes.
Now, trying to say
"happy Lunar New Year"
with a shot clock
and when you've over-hydrated,
it's really bad.
And when I practiced it,
it sounded mangled.
It was awful.
And so, I really was like,
"Please, God,
just say this properly,
and you'll be okay."
And once that was done,
I'm like, "Cool.
Trump, whatever."
-Nice job.
Very, very nice job.
Moving on to the name
you just mentioned, you were --
-I'm sorry.
-That's all right.
We bring him up, too.
It sounds like he's going to
declare a national emergency
over this border wall.
I guess, to some degree,
we can't be surprised.
But what is your sort of
first reaction to this?
-I don't think
laughter's appropriate, but...
Yeah, actually, laughter.
-Yeah.
-I think he realizes he was
outmatched by Nancy Pelosi,
that he received --
[ Cheers and applause ]
That he got less than
he would have gotten
had he not had a temper tantrum.
But more than anything,
it's not real.
There is no emergency.
It is not national.
It is in his head.
And he will be sued
so many times.
But what he's
looking forward to --
and I think we will give him --
is that we will have
a histrionic fit about this,
and then we'll realize
it's just like everything else
he hasn't done.
Why are we reacting
to yet another untruth?
-So would your advice be,
then...
[ Applause ]
...to just ignore it?
Because obviously, you want to
bring legal challenges,
it would seem.
-Oh, we should sue him,
of course.
Absolutely.
Because left unchecked,
he will declare
a national emergency
because tanning beds are
disappearing from the shelves.
-Right. Yeah.
-But in all seriousness,
I do think there is --
there is necessary response,
but it doesn't have to be public
and it doesn't
have to be constant.
We validate his behavior
by treating it as serious.
What we should treat it as
is fraudulent
and fraught with egotism,
and that means sue him,
let him lose,
and don't give him the
credibility of treating this
as serious.